[Musique]
je
alwyn morris et le moins qu'on puisse
dire entourée de plein de monde pour la
montée des marches de the french
dispatch le nouveau film de wes anderson
puisque a à peu près tout hollywood
dans ce film là et il était avec nous
sur les marches ainsi que les invités
festival regarder ça
[Musique]
quoi
la cérémonie d'ouverture quelques jours
après il en reste coi vous avez été
super oh mercy bas il en reste ses
compliments qui me font sourire merci
beaucoup non c'était génial c'était
c'était quand même cédé contre quand on
va dans un parc d'attractions et qu'on a
peur de la plus grande attraction mais
on veut quand même la faire mais c'était
simple et alors bah alors c'était génial
là j'étais j'ai été mouillé il y avait
de l'eau y avait des descendants des
remontées c'est trop bien et à
l'apparent jodie foster et à la fin on
est super contents boileau et en plus
avec plusieurs photos faisait quand on
sort de la traction da toujours des
photos mails sont des galets cela j'en
avais déjà dit bon ça se passe
les délibérations du jury des moments
très émouvants
à la fois on est tous extrêmement
émirati passeront on voit des oeuvres
comme ça qui sont à la fois percutante
avec des points de vue différents ça
nous permet de voyager
et puis je trouve que toutes les options
incroyablement courageuse
ça demande beaucoup de courage et on
essaye d'en prendre soin
[Musique]
bonjour didier vous allez bien oui
la dernière fois qu'on s'est parlé
oliver stone vous présentiez direct sur
naples sur la plage avec 7 en projection
de la version restaurée
comment ça s'est passé très beau coup
aujourd'hui on a fait mentir aujourd'hui
c'est pourquoi nous sommes en main alors
ce documentaire vous étudiez la faire
sur toutes ses coutures
je suis moi je suis fier l'ancien des
nouvelles ce ne sont que des faits que
je présente que les tripes je les
examine est ce que vont nous produire et
à changer on n'a pas du tout non non non
je reste les positions vous êtes
toujours convaincu qu'on ne sait pas
tout sur cette affaire n'en sait pas
plus que ça et c'est un feu nourri
c'est une situation impossible aux soins
ce n'est pas que ça il ya d'autres
personnes impliquées dont les services
la cia et autres ça va beaucoup plus
loin
c'est pas un mystère
[Musique]
cinéma et ce batteur le cinéma est de
retour et lorsque l'on voit un film
comme celui du web
c'est un amour pour la france c'est un
amour pour le cinéma c'est un privilège
vraiment d'être ici présents encore une
fois avec ce film je suis très ému que
l'on soit tous ensemble
petit à petit se sont rassemblés la vie
d'avant on se soutient mutuellement en
soutiennent notre industrie tout autour
de la planète pour ce que tous ceux qui
ont souffert pendant la pandémie
il faut reconstruire quelque chose
ensemble faut persévérer
[Musique]
bonjour bill murray comment ça va ça va
très bien j'ai feinté stick arrivé en
can
un autre fois en france bin oui
expériences extraordinaires habités à
angoulême apprendre l'histoire d
angoulême
c'est des beaux habits cement et le
cognac est juste qu harry évidemment
merci beaucoup ville merci infiniment
[Musique]
benicio del toro tilda swinton en face
de moi wenzhou est en train de créer de
l'histoire aujourd'hui c'est le premier
quart à venir jusqu'au tapis
la prochaine fois c'est ton bateau mais
c'est en métal pour ce film
wen il est unique pourquoi il est unique
il sait ce qu'il veut et il sait qu'il
aime travail avec ses copains et il
arrive à nous faire venir est en fait
tous ensemble
mais chaque réalisateur est unique
lui il est peut-être juste un peu plus
unie que les autres et c'était comment
on travaille dans son premier film
français mais c'était nouveau
c'était très nouveau et votre rôle est
incroyable votre personnage est
incroyable
pouvez-vous dire quelques mots sur votre
personnage qu'il a fait
j'ai joué un détenu qui est entre
découvert par un autre détenu détenus
joué par hedren brody et hilda elle
arrive elle est critique d'art elle a
écrit pour le journal étant que j'écris
un article sur le personnage de benicio
temps que celle une histoire entre 4 et
citoyen
[Musique]
c'est comment d'être dans un film avec
le tilda swinton bill murray adrian
brody venue de spiegel angénieux font
des bêtises derrière qu'est-ce qu'ils
font raconter nos habits les lanières
masquent avec un visage
il avait caché là vous avez vous avez
vous avez l'air bien vous marrer comme
dans le film ça a l'air super relax
super détendu supérieur c'est une
famille c'est génial d'être 2005 comme
ça c'est trop bien plus en plus mal
d'ennuis talons
on est content l'expérience bosser avec
west c'est vraiment pareille date après
date c'est trop bien vous verrez vous
pouvez dans le jeu c'est moi j'ai bien
vu que c'était le meilleur moment de
cette histoire et c'est sublime
entièrement d'accord avec vous il a
merci infiniment merci beaucoup
[Musique]
comment ça va timothée très bien trop
thériault oui super cela comment c'était
cette expérience avec des supers c1
et plus grands réalisateurs américains
comptent encore aussi dans l'histoire de
la cité cinéma j'ai un grand honneur et
essaya laisser non mais c'est la montée
des marches si elle est merci thimoté
[Musique]
pour moi
on se retrouve demain à 20h35 kicha
spécial cannes c'est sur canal+